rompió su silencio para revelar
principios de alto riesgo el tenista
novak djokovic ha manifestado que para
él no vacunarse es más importante que
ganar premios
no puedo viajar a la mayoría de los
torneos en este momento si ese es el
precio que estoy dispuesto a pagar nunca
estuve en contra de la vacunación pero
siempre ha apoyado la libertad de elegir
lo que pones en tu cuerpo
djokovic indicó que no quiere estar
asociado con el movimiento anti vacunas
en enero provocó una ira generalizada en
australia cuando se le otorgó una
exención médica para competir en el
primer gran torneo del año debido a que
había contraído kobe 19 en diciembre
tras dos cancelaciones de visas dos
impugnaciones judiciales y varios días
en un hotel de detención de inmigrantes
djokovic fue deportado de australia las
autoridades advirtieron que su presencia
alentaría el sentimiento y el malestar
contra la vacunación ello significó que
el 20 veces ganador de torneos gran slam
perdió la oportunidad de convertirse en
el jugador masculino más exitoso de
todos los tiempos con 21 títulos en
estos torneos
djokovic está listo para regresar a la
acción en un torneo atp en dubai la
próxima semana el jugador serbio ha
manifestado que tiene la mente abierta
para recibir una dosis de la vacuna en
el futuro